Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
in the chapter
of vigilance
of Allah's observation,
vigilance of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
anger
in
authored by
Abu Zakaria
and
we are coming in to the final
narrations of the chapter. This
narration
is a lengthy narration. This is
the sixth narration in the chapter,
the 65th narration in the book. It's one
of the lengthier narrations. Usually, we
would skip over the very long narrations
simply because
we'd never get out of them. It would
we'd spend the entire month at the rate
we're going in them. However, this
narration
is a narration which many of us have
heard before
and is not
in
is not one of those narrations that
we need to
explain very much
as the narration itself is pretty
obvious, pretty clear.
He says
what's his name?
Abdahman Iben Sakur. And he is from D.
And which year did he become Muslim?
Yeah. is the year of it's a difference
of opinion whether he was there for
whether he came at the end. However, it
is not a difference of opinion on
whether or not he received from the
spoils of war of the the
he was given a portion and what year
did he pass away?
[Arabic recitation]
He was also appointed as the
official MUI and Muhad in Medina during
the time of
and his students exceed 1,000 students.
Now, that doesn't sound a lot. When
we're speaking about his students exceed
1,000 students, we mean students who
later went on to become teachers. As for
students who learned or studied and and
you know and then and then
took another path in life, they are
almost innumerable.
Abu
says that he heard the prophet
say.
[Silence]
He says that three men from Benny is
one a leper,
the the other a bald man, the third, a
blind man. Allah
wished to test them. And so he sent to
them an angel, meaning in the form of a
man.
And so he came first to the Abas, the
leper, and he said to him, "If you could
have anything, what is the thing you
most desire in the world?"
And he said,
a a nice complexion and clear skin
and that this illness that I am plagued
with be gone from me.
This illness which has caused people to
be disgusted by me.
And so the angel wiped him wiped him.
wiped his arm or his head. It's unclear
which. And by Allah's miracle, he was
given the best of complexions. All of
that leprosy that was in his skin and in
his body was miraculously gone. But he
didn't stop there. The angel then said
to him,
"And so what kind of property or what
kind of wealth is most beloved to you?
for
[Silence]
He said, "And which type of property do
you most desire?"
He said, "Camels." It's the thing that
he really likes. And this will come into
play later
because what a person desires of this
world,
this ties into that person's
temperament.
Correct?
Is there anything wrong with a person
having liking camels? No, there's
nothing wrong with a person liking
camels.
However, are there aspects
of camels behavior
which if found in a human being would
prove to be terrible traits? Yes,
there are. And for this reason, the
prophet sallallah.aii Wasallam said
that arrogance and hidiness
and highness
and
un
unearned pride is found most usually in
the shepherds of camels
and humility
and humbleness and meekness. This is
most usually found in the shepherds of
sheep
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Why is that?
Because if a person spends his time
around a particular animal,
in order to survive with that animal,
they will start to develop a temperament
which will complement that animal.
person will start to take on traits
of that animal. And camels are not known
for their humility. Camels are not known
for
their meekness.
They're not known for their gentleness.
Camels likewise are very vengeful,
arrogant creatures that are usually
that are usually very unforgiving at
heart.
So camels hold grudges.
They hold grudges in an unhealthy way
and they seek vengeance and retribution
to the point that it will mean their
or spell their demise or expiration.
This is because of the anger and
arrogance that is usually found in
camels. So this man asked for camels
and so he was given a pregnant sheic
camel and then the angel said to him,
"May Allah bless you through this camel.
[Silence]
Then he came to the bald man and he
asked him the same question. If you
could have anything, what would you what
would you ask for? He said that I would
be given a nice lush full head of hair
and that this you know this this
balding and this this bald head of mine
be done away with. And so he wiped
over him and he was given a nice
beautiful
lush head of hair. And then he asked
him, "What type of property would you
most desire?"
He said, "Cattle." And so he was given a
pregnant
cow.
And he was told,
"May Allah bless you through this cow."
And so notice the wording. Each time he
is asked, he they the angel asks the
person, he says, "What do you wish you
had the most?" He says, "I wish I had
this. I wish I had that." Listen to how
the speech pattern changes with the with
the blind man.
He came to the blind man and he said,
"What do you desire most in the world?"
Listen to his response. He said,
he said, "Which do you if you could ask
for anything, what would you ask for?"
He said, "That Allah restore my vision
for me so I could see others."
Now, there's two differences here in
what he said and what the other two
said. The first two they were asked, "If
you could wish for anything, what would
it be?" First of all, there's no mention
of Allah for them. They said, "I wish I
had better skin. I wish I had better
hair."
The second difference is
that what they wanted
was something of vanity so people would
see them
something for other people.
However, this man
first of all he didn't say I just want
my sight back. He said that Allah
restore my sight.
So first of all he knows that it is
Allah who took his sight and it is Allah
who restores the sight but second of all
he said so that I can see others.
This is for him to see others not so
people will accept me and people will
me and it's not about you know you
know what people say often
and you can learn a lot about a person
or people
by listening to their proclamations
proclamations about themselves. Right?
When you first meet people, unless a
person who is very calculated in how
they speak, person who is very
well mannered and someone you know
who who weighs his words. Most times
people out themselves by their
proclamations.
I
never hold anything in my heart. Ask
anybody about me. Everyone knows I have
the cleanest heart in the whole wide
world. This is usually the words of
someone who has the most
grudgefilled heart.
Someone will say,
"I do this only for Allah. It's all I
care about. All I care about is that
Allah
just forgive me. That's all I think
about. I don't care what anybody thinks.
Usually, it's exactly the opposite. Why
is that? Because people
usually speak. They say what they don't
do. Usually, not the believer.
And when we say believer, we're speaking
about a person who has learned and
disciplined himself over perhaps
decades.
This is natural. This is the how the
human being is naturally. It is only
someone who has disciplined himself over
decades
that if they are to make a proclamation
not out of vanity about themselves,
it can probably be taken to heart.
Otherwise, most people speak about what
they don't do.
And so you can even tell this by a
society. What the society speaks most
about, pride theirelves mostly about is
usually the things that are most lacking
in that society.
Because humanity simultaneously
You know, we have subconsciously we know
what's wrong with us and subconsciously
we try to overcompensate with our with
our words. So if we have a guilty
conscience that usually comes up in the
way that we speak.
So the things that we proclaim the most
are usually the things which are which
we are most ashamed of things that we
know we should change are most in need
of change about ourselves.
And so for instance I don't care what
anybody thinks.
What kind of human being doesn't care
about what anybody thinks? What makes us
powerful as human beings? What gives us
power? Is it our muscles or is it our
brains? Or is it our connections and our
ability to move other people to our
will? That's what power is. Who doesn't
care about their own reputation?
Everybody does.
That's something that is integral to the
human being. That's why we've conquered
the earth is because of our ability to
hold reputations with one another and
bend other people to our will.
And so when a person makes such a
proclamation, it's usually quite the
opposite. Usually what motivates them
and moves them is what other people
think, whether it's right or wrong. And
so these first two individuals,
they're worried even though they're ill,
even though they're their own well. What
are they worried about? They didn't say
that this leprosy go away, that I have a
nice head of hair so that you know
so that my quality of life will will
get better. Rather, the statement is so
that other people will accept me. People
are not accepting me because of this
illness. I want it to go away so I can
be a big shot again. And they have no
mention of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
They've already failed the test.
However,
that's because they were not prepared
for the test beforehand. We will
continue this inshallah tomorrow.
Subhanahu
subhanahu
and
[Silence]
set up. How you doing?